what's the best baseball movie of all
time sandlock what is on your Fried
Chicken Sandwich hot honey what's the
most memorable thing you've heard a fan
yell at you from the stands Brandon Mars
why do you smell so bad I heard that you
come out every day with your hair wet
it's clean it's not greasy it is clean
it's clean it's it's clean it may not
look pretty but that's okay I'm not
going for that it's clean and it's and
it's wet that's all that's all I care
about what is a hobby you wish you could
spend more time doing playing chess
what's your favorite show of all time
the office if you could play the role of
any character in any movie what movie
would it be Denzel Washington and safe
house who is the most exciting player in
the MLB right now stter what is your
go-to order at a ballpark concession
stands I'm going to go with a Gizzy got
to fully dressed if I'm hungry a little
a cheeseburger with fries